PROFESSOR: So here is
a problem example based
on Griffith's problem 9.3.
So it's a two-state system, and
we'll call the states a and b,
with energy's Ea and Eb.
And we'll call omega 0
the difference Ea minus Eb
over h bar.
So those are energy
eigenstates, which
means that H0 is really Ea Eb.
We represent the first
column vector by the state a.
The second state is the
second column vector
with entry 0 and 1--
is the state b.
That's why the matrix
looks like that.
And then you put a perturbation.
And the perturbation,
delta H, is
going to take the form U delta
t, where U is a matrix that
has Uaa, Uab, Uba, Ubb--
the matrix elements.
And they're simple enough.
It's a 0 here and an alpha
here, and an alpha dagger here.
It should be a Hermitian matrix,
and that's the way it is.
The letter U, I
guess, is not great,
because it suggests unitary.
But maybe I should put a v.
I'll leave it, to not create
problems with my notation.
So here is the question.
This is your
perturbation Hamiltonian.
Actually, I wrote it wrong here.
It's a delta function of t.
That's delta H. So in terms
of H0 applies everywhere,
H0 applies everywhere,
and in the middle
there is a delta H for
one little instant.
So what happens here?
We're going to try to
figure out what's going on.
But the question will
be posed as follows.
Assume the system is in the
state a for t less than 0.
Let's ask the probability
to be in the state
b for t greater than 0.
Find the probability to
be, and be greater than 0.
So what's going on?
Here are the states a and b.
They were eigenstates of H0.
If you had the system in the
state a-- that's an energy
eigenstate--
it would stay in
the state a forever.
It wouldn't do anything.
Indeed if whoever
prepared that state,
ever since he or she prepared
it, it has stayed in the state
a until time equals 0.
But then the system
is kicked and it's
kicked with some delta
function strength,
and in the off-diagonal terms.
That's pretty important.
It's not kicked on the diagonal
terms, it's kicked here.
So these terms suggest a
transition from state a
to b here.
And presumably, due to this,
the system will transition.
And when it transitions, it
must transition instantaneously
in a sense.
Because if it takes
time to transition,
the delta function
asks for zero time.
If it takes time to transition,
then it would not transition.
Because after the delta
function has come and gone,
the system doesn't
change anymore.
So it really has to
transition instantaneously.
So at time equals
0, you must generate
a probability or an amplitude
to be in the state b already.
So there must be an
immediate transition
in which the state,
originally, at time less than 0
was the state a, but at
time a little bit after zero
must be a little bit of
a plus a little bit of b.
So this is t0 minus,
0 minus, and 0 plus.
At 0 minus, it's
a, and at 0 plus
must be something like that.
Because if at 0
plus it's still a,
it's going to stay a forever.
So it must have some amplitude
to be at b at 0 plus.
So you're having your first
transition amplitude problem--
how does an interaction make you
jump from one state to another?
Now my letters here, alpha
and beta, are pretty bad--
U and V maybe--
because I have an alpha
there in the interaction.
And maybe, if you
think perturbatively,
you would say, look,
if alpha is very small,
there must be a small
transition probability.
If the perturbation
is of order alpha,
maybe I expect the perturbed
state to be of order alpha.
So maybe, after all,
this is like alpha times
b, or proportional to alpha
times b, a number here.
And this one-- well,
if alpha is very small,
that's probably
roughly about 1 still--
a little bit less,
alpha squared less,
for probability conservation.
But I expect an alpha b here.
So OK, when you're given
a problem like that,
under normal conditions
it's a good idea
to think about it before
trying to solve it.
And I think we've done a
little bit of thinking.
We've realized the state
stays in a after a while,
and immediately must transition
into some other state.
And once it's in that
other state, its going
to remain in that state forever
because those are energy
eigenstates, so you're going
to get exponentials of E
to the minus iEt.
But this is going to be that.
OK, so let's solve this.
Here is our equation.
Let's try to write
it for this case.
So I would have i
h bar C a dot of t.
We have two states--
1 and 2-- but here is a and b.
So you would have i omega a
then something, t and delta H
a with something.
Well, the delta H is
clear that it can only
be a delta H from a to b.
Because there's Uab.
There's only that
transition amplitude.
And then it would
be an i omega ab,
which was defined as omega 0,
delta Hab of time, cb of time.
And that's the only term that
exists here from the sum.
You could sum over a and b, but
we saw that over a, you get 0.
So there's just this term.
And then we have i H
bar Cb dot of [? t ?]
is equal to E to the i.
And now you're
going to have ba--
so delta Hba of t Ca of t.
And here I would
have omega ba, which
is the opposite sign as
omega ab, which we anyway
call omega 0.
So here's minus i omega 0 t.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
perturbation disappears?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Does the
perturbation vanish?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Because delta Haa is equal
to 0, and therefore there's
no coupling to Ca.
And delta Hbb is 0 from
that matrix element.
And therefore, you
cannot couple b to b.
And now I'll just write
it i H bar Ca dot of t,
i H bar Cb dot of t is
equal E to the i omega 0t.
Delta Hab was alpha
delta of time--
Cb of t.
And this is E to
the minus i omega
0t, alpha star delta of time--
Ca of t.
Hba was Uba, which is alpha
star times the delta function
of time.
Here I have a delta
function of time.
It says that this only matters
when time is equal to 0.
So things are a
little delicate here.
But let's see.
Can I write here--
well, if I have f of
x times delta of x,
we know this is f of
0 times delta of x.
Because anyway, only
zeros [INAUDIBLE]..
So I can put time equals
0 here, and forget
about this exponential-- have
alpha delta of t, cb of t,
and here have alpha
star delta of t Ca of t.
Everybody happy so far?
But here, I have Cb of t
and Ca of t, and a delta t.
So I should put alpha
delta of t Cb at 0,
and alpha star
delta of t Ca at 0.
Right?
Yes?
People look less convinced,
which I congratulate you
for doubting this.
This would be bad.
It seems like I'm just
following the logic,
but I've gone too far now.
Why did I go too far?
First, this is going
to be a disaster.
Because in many ways, we don't
know what these numbers are.
You see, we are argued
that this is going
to change this continuously.
Those numbers are going to
change this continuously.
At time equals 0--
before time equals 0,
Ca was 1 and Cb was 0.
But after time equals 0, Cb
is going to be a number--
something that we don't know.
So the delta function,
which does it
hiy-- the one before 0, the
one after 0, the average?
What does it do?
This is a case where you
have a delta function that we
don't know what it's doing.
So this is totally wrong.
So I will just stop there.
And I will consider,
however these two equations.
So we have the equations
now in a nice way.
I'll reconsider them.
And we are facing a
difficulty, the difficulty
of the delta function not
allowing us to treat nicely
the transition of i h bar Ca dot
is equal to alpha delta of Cb,
and i h bar Cb dot equal
alpha star delta of t Ca.
Well now, the only way to
resolve this difficulty
is to think about
this physically,
and introduce a regulator
that is physical.
You see, no signal in the world
really is a delta function.
Nothing becomes infinite, and
nothing lasts for zero time.
So this interaction,
this delta function,
represents a function of time--
delta of time.
It's a spike, but we can think
of it as a regulated thing.
You've regulated delta
functions in all kinds of ways.
It might be useful to
regulate it as follows,
as a function of time that
is 0 before time equals 0,
it's 0 after some
time, t star, and it
has height 1 over t star.
That's a picture of
a delta function.
It has the right area at least.
And we're going to
think of this system
as exactly doing that
in between, for t,
in the interval 0 to t star.
The delta function
is going to be
replaced by this function,
this constant function.
So it will have i
h bar h Ca dot is
equal to alpha over t star Cb.
And i h bar Cb dot is equal
to alpha star over t sub star.
Now the star doesn't mean
complex conjugation for t.
It's just a number, a glyph
called t0 or something
like that.
And this is true for
this time interval.
And then you would say, look,
I have two problems with this.
First, you've entered
this at t star,
and now your calculation is
going to depend on t star.
And then the answer is
And what are you going
to put for t star?
Well, that better not happen.
We have to go on a limb.
Many times when you do a
calculation of something,
you go on a limb.
You say something,
and see if it works.
This seems reasonable.
And what we expect
is that we will
find an answer that this
independent on this t star.
So that we can take this star
to 0 and make sense of it.
The other question
that could come
is that, oh, that was
your delta function.
So one seconds, you used
delta function for this.
Maybe we have to put back these
terms, these exponentials.
We set them to 1.
But then you could
say, look, I don't
think I have to put them back.
Why?
Because I can choose t
star as small as I want,
such that omega t star,
which is the possible value
that this can get, at most,
is like 10 to the minus 60.
And therefore, this phase is
going to be 0, essentially,
and that's going to be 1.
So I claim that I don't have
to worry about this anymore.
So what do we have?
We have two simple differential
equations, like this.
With the conditions that
Ca at time equals 0 is 1,
and Cb at time equals 0 is 0.
The state before the delta
function hits is given by that.
And now what we want
to know is, how much is
Ca after the delta function and
Cb after the delta function?
So for that, we have
all the tools needed.
I can take this equation.
This is a coupled
system of equations.
It's a simple system.
I could differentiate
again here.
And I get a Ca double-dot, Cb
dot, and use this equation.
So you get the equation-- if you
differentiate again, take a dot
to form Ca double-dot, you
get that Ca double-dot is
equal to minus alpha over
h bar t star squared Ca.
You can see that you put the i
h bar here, take the derivative,
you get an alpha times
an alpha star, which
is length of alpha squared.
And the h bar appears two
times, t star appears two times.
This is an oscillating solution.
So that's simple enough.
So what happens here is that
Ca will oscillate in time,
and you will have a
solution of the form
Ca is equal to a constant, beta
0 cosine of alpha h bar t star
t, plus beta 1 sine of
alpha p, over h bar t star.
And if you wish, Cb
from the first equation
is proportional to Ca dot.
And Ca dot is going
to be of the form beta
0 sine off this thing, plus
beta 1 cosine of this thing.
OK, so we've turned this into
a tractable problem because
of flattening the
delta function.
And your initial conditions--
again, Cb must vanish at time
equals 0.
So if Cb must vanish at time
equals 0, beta 1 must be 0.
If beta 1 is zero,
this term is gone,
and Ca was 1 for time equals 0.
So beta 0 is 1.
Therefore, Ca is equal to cosine
alpha t, over h star t star
Ca of t.
And Cb of t, you can calculate
it from the top equation.
You take the derivative
of Ca, and divide
by alpha multiplied by t star.
I'll let you do it.
You get minus i alpha,
over alpha, sine, alpha t
over ht star.
OK, we solved for the functions.
We know what's going to happen.
And now, what did we want?
We wanted to know what are
those things for later times,
for times t star or more.
Now you cannot use this
equation beyond time t star,
because they assumed the
delta function is there.
So what you have
to figure out is
what are these coefficients
at time t star.
And those would be the
coefficients at any later time,
because there's no
more Hamiltonian.
So Ca at t greater than
t star is, in fact,
equal to Ca at t star.
And Ca at t star,
happily, is a number
that doesn't depend on t star--
cosine alpha over h bar.
And Cb at t greater than
t star is Cb at t star.
It doesn't change any
more after the delta
function has turned off.
And Cb at t star is minus
i alpha over alpha--
alpha over alpha, like this,
times sine of alpha over h bar.
And this is really
what you wanted.
Now you know what the state
is doing after the delta
function has turned on.
It has this amplitude
to be in the b state.
And it is, as we
predicted-- remember,
this is like the face of alpha,
because the alpha is alpha
times its face--
length of alpha times it
face, and it will cancel.
And here you have
sine of this quantity.
So it is proportional.
Cb is proportional to alpha.
And that's exactly
what you would expect.
So just to complete the
story, let's write the answer.
And what is the answer?
Phi of t for t greater than
0 is the coefficient Ca
of t, which was cosine,
alpha over h bar,
times E to the minus
iEat, over h bar a.
Remember, the solution is
Ca E to the minus iEta.
And then the other one, which
is minus i alpha, over alpha,
sine of alpha over h bar, e to
the minus iEbt over h bar, b.
That is the state after the
delta function has turned on.
And what is the
probability to be
found in the state b, time t?
It would be b times
the state squared.
So you get-- b will couple just
to that. b with b gives you 1.
This is a phase.
Sine squared of
this thing is sine
squared of alpha over h bar.
What is the
probability to be in a?
It's a psi of t.
And in this case, it
will be cosine squared
of alpha over h bar.
And it's very handy
that cosine squared
plus sine squared is
equal to 1, because it
has to be either in a or on b.
And it's kind of
interesting, if you
were doing this in
perturbation-- we solved it
exactly.
If you were doing this
in perturbation theory,
we would have found P of b
proportional to alpha squared.
Because the first term
in the expansion here,
in terms of the interaction.